das hört sich ein bisschen komisch an
ich hätte gern einmal genau das was der
vor mir hatte geht das und dann komme
ich da an und die vor mir bestellt
einfach zwei cookies super was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
leute heute starten wir mit einer neuen
24 stunden challenge und es wird glaube
ich die verrückteste 24 und elend oder
die ich sage mal so die am wenigsten
unvorhersehbaren talent ich muss direkt
am anfang mal sagen die idee habe ich
nicht von mir dann von einem
amerikanischen youtuber ich verlinke
euch das video sehr gerne in der video
beschreibung es geht heute nämlich darum
also wir haben wie immer halt in den 24
stunden drei mahlzeiten ihr kennt das ja
irgendwie bisher als sie aus oder ich
könnte jetzt auch entspannt am bahnhof
trinken machen wir danach auf jeden fall
haben wir ein frühstück mittagessen
abendessen und ich werde jedes mal sagen
ich hätte geld genau das gleiche wie die
personen genau vor mir
ob das jetzt im 34 ob das jetzt im
restaurant ist ob das sonst wo ist was
weiß ich es geht halt immer noch um die
person formel dass die person formel
bestimmt mein essen und wenn ich glück
habe bestellt die was was ich gut finde
und wenn ich pech arbeit nicht darum
gehe jetzt will ich eigentlich echt mega
damit kann man auch ziemlich viele
andere lustige sachen anstellen wenn man
halt immer genau das gleiche nimmt wie
der vor allem wenn ihr bock drauf habe
dass ich das noch mal öfter machen dass
du auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal doch
nach oben abonniert den kanal jetzt
fertig schon zum dritten mal in drei
minuten die polizei lagen wir fahren
jetzt erst mal los weil es mit tag und
ja immer sehen muss finden geht heute
was geht ab ich bin jetzt schon im auto
fahrer gerade hier also nicht weit von
mir da gibst du alles mögliche also ich
hab gedacht ich fahr jetzt erstmal durch
irgendeinen 3 und zwar ehrlich zu sein
ich war schon ewig polizei kamera und
ich war schon ewig nicht mehr bei kiew
sie also wirklich keine ahnung ist schon
über ein jahr her oder so dass auch
sonaten habe ich gar nicht so einen
kasten überblick was es da geht also
natürlich so ein bisschen da gibts halt
chicken wertes gedacht jetzt bin ich
auch noch über rot gefahren er heute bin
ich ein ganz schlechtes vorbild kleiner
fand den usa
das habe ich so gehört ich glaube das
stimmt auch sogar heißt das nicht mehr
kentucky fried chicken sondern darf nur
noch cave sie heißt weil das chicken
eine so derartig schlechte qualität hat
das ist irgendwie hundefutter gleicht
und dann das da gab es irgendwie so ein
streit oder soja also wir fahren dahin
bestellen das gleiche wie das auto vor
mir und ich guck mal was die leute guckt
mal hier ist casey und da hinten also
dass beides direkte einander da ist auch
noch irgendwas wir wollen uns mal hier
rein blöd wäre wenn jetzt gar keiner vor
mir hier ja ich war ja das ist jetzt ein
bisschen blöd das ist einfach keiner vor
mir also der drive ist komplett leer das
heißt ich muss noch warten bis
irgendwann für die leute ist das normal
ich stehe jetzt bestimmt schon fünf
minuten dann ist es noch kein schwein da
rein gefahren vielleicht hat das ja
irgendeinen grund weil ich glaube
irgendwie diese filiale läuft gar nicht
gut ohne spaß ich sehe ja schon über
zehn minuten und ich habe weder jemanden
da reingehen sehen noch durch den drei
tagen sehen also wirklich komisch schon
mit 12 11 also genau mit leute das ist
mir jetzt wirklich zu blöd ich stehe
schon so lange gar nicht irgendwie durch
auch kein mensch da wenn ich mir einmal
in einem monat so was wohl hier dann ist
die scheiße im abfall und jetzt wo ich
so brauch ist kein mensch da man so
leute jetzt habe ich mal kurz zum drive
gewechselt die ist jetzt wenigstens
deutschland freundlich theorien und die
spende kommt aber auch daran
ich bin da kommt doch da an leute vor
ihm eine klimaanlage hat voll in das
mikrofon der kamera geballert deswegen
ich habe ihr nur gesagt dass ich so
gestresst sogenannte und irgendwo was
bekommen haben aber jetzt geht es weiter
das hier ist alles wir sehen uns gleich
leute endlich wieder zu hause
ich habe ihnen dann getränke ich glaube
dass eine cola light und hier des mc
sunday mit erdbeer so habe ich
persönlich noch nie gegessen
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt und was in
der tüte ist weiß ich noch gar nicht
checken wir gleich mal ab also ich sag
mal so was hätte schlechter laufen
übrigens habe ich noch so zwei euro
gespendet ich habe irgendwie so cd dafür
bekommen als spende von über sowas immer
ein bisschen unsicher ob das auch
wirklich ankommen könnte mir gerne eure
meinung in die kommentare schreiben also
wenn man so an irgendwelche
restaurantketten geld oder so kommt das
dann wirklich bei hilfsbedürftigen an
oder er nicht okay leute also die tüte
ist eher klein
was bedeutet da ist wahrscheinlich nicht
viel drin ich würde mal sagen ein bürger
fühlt sich zumindest so anderen
cheeseburger wäre voll in ordnung mehr
schicken burger
damit kann arbeiten und ein doppel
cheeseburger schaut mal hier
das würde den blick die kritiker gar
nicht gefallen der käse ist schon feste
clip leute was geht
bevor wir gleich weitermachen ich habe
mir gedacht ich das erste mal ganz
entspannt aus max anders um
nachdem ich mir gestern habe ich das
schon in die kühltruhe gepackt und
irgendwie habe ich dann vergessen
ich habe mir gedacht ich lass das ganze
video über diese jacke hier an einfach
so halt jetzt weiter hat bin ich mal
gespannt was mich dann hinführt ich
hoffe dann habe ich noch mehr glück ja
wir sehen
wir machen weiter ich habe noch keine
ahnung wohin ist gehe ich bin doch noch
also das ist wirklich so witzig wenn du
über 18 sein eigenes auto keine ahnung
also ich persönlich finde ich lustig
probiert das sehr gern mit euren
freunden aus schickt mit ein video davon
wieder das bestellt würde mich freuen
wenn ich dann auch in meiner instagram
story die post weil das mir über
instagram alex wie es weitergeht soll
ich versuche die ganze zeit diese dumme
kamera dazu platzieren wenn jetzt wieder
runter fällt weil ich hatte das schon
mal so weit dass auch gehalten hat
hallo hallo
das hört sich ein bisschen komisch an
ich hätte gern einmal genau das was der
vor mir hatte geht das ja ja genau der
vor mir scheint dass jetzt viele leute
im auto glaube wenn ich jetzt hier in
diesem menü habt dann ich habe noch
keine ahnung was ist nur weil da auch
nichts angezeigt wurde aber die dachte
sich wahrscheinlich auch so was wäre
jetzt leute schalte das damals extrem
lange bei denen wir sind hier kein gutes
zeichen
danke leute das ist hier die tüte das
ist das einzige was jetzt bekommen dies
ziemlich schwer
also in dem auto saßen glaube ich drei
leute und das hat komischerweise nur 9
euro
890 oder so gekostet als ich hätte jetzt
eigentlich mit mehr gerechnet
es riecht irgendwie ein bisschen nach
fisch
gibt es überhaupt viel starb war das
nicht schon extrem nach frischen fisch
border ist 100 prozentig fisch drin
also wir sehen uns vielleicht wieder hat
leute ich hab mir gedacht warum sie auf
jeden fall rein gucken
wir haben ein peking so was mache ich
eigentlich nicht so gerne
und hier sind jetzt dickenberg 19 euro
für das was willst du dich nicht auf
hallo ihr gesehen die hat total gepumpt
und acht leute ich möchte erstmal weg
stehen bisher schlecht fällt mir dann
irgendwie vielleicht eine soße dabei
oder so wenigstens welcher mensch holt
sich denn so ein weg ging und diese
chicken wings ohne soße und ohne
getränkt ist also bin ich der einzige
der sagt also das würde ich mir im leben
nicht holen
ich habe am anfang noch gesagt so ticken
da geht's chicken wings das finde ich
alles wenn ich mir also fast module dann
ist meistens einfach nur ein
cheeseburger auch so diese fetten bürger
sind gar nicht so meins also ich es sehr
gerne einen richtig guten berge aber so
bei mcdonald's und big mac zum beispiel
feiere ich auch nicht ich bin ja selber
schuld
ja bis spät also leute jetzt mal ohne
rum zu holen aber das ist doch einfach
viel zu trocken die von dagegen habe ich
noch nie probiert wollte ich eigentlich
auch nie das ist glaubt sogar wiking ich
selber obwohl ich habe keine ahnung ich
würde uns beides sagen verstehe ich so
eingestellt aber das hier vor allem die
sind auch also meiner meinung nach die
das wachstum nachhaltig aus und schmeckt
auch nicht woanders nicht ein barbecue
tipp oder so dass man werde ich jetzt
noch etliche leute ich habe jetzt
mittlerweile auch gecheckt warum das so
teuer bleibt man hier 69 oder 15 apag
ich denke mal ich habe diesen 15 ein
parkproblem ist aber ich habe jetzt
schon zwei mal durchgezählt und das sind
wirklich nur 12 allerdings verstehe ich
das nicht heute das geht ab gerade
aufgestanden die unglaubliche bald
richtig die sonne strahlen klar hier
will das freut mich erinnere mich jetzt
erstmals frühstücken zumindest dann wenn
meine haare getrocknet und ich habe mir
gedacht wir fahren einfach mal zu starr
war ich weiß nicht ob es hier so einen
drive starbucks gibt könnte eigentlich
gut sein weil ich habe davon irgendwann
mal was gehört will ich jetzt sofort auf
falls es nicht so ist gehe ich einfach
in
die filiale und bestellt das wie der der
vor mir dran ist das ding ist zwar klar
ist es jetzt die letzte mahlzeit in den
24 stunden wenn er jetzt allerdings nur
irgend so ein kaffee bestellen habe ich
wieder ein problem und frage mich aber
ich hoffe wir kriegen das irgendwie hin
ich bin gespannt
wir sehen uns dann gleich im auto leute
ich hab mal gegoogelt und es gibt
tatsächlich in köln für starbucks noch
keine aber es nicht so schlimm wir
machen uns jetzt auf den weg zu einer
ganz normalen filiale und ich hoffe ich
krieg da einen geilen kaffee mit
karamell geschmack und dazu noch ich
weiß gar nicht wie es heißt habe ich
letzten mal da gegessen irgendwie so ein
baguette war das schon eis weil ich hab
hunger haben jetzt in irgend einem
parkhaus gelandet von so einem kaufhaus
und hier gibt es jetzt nichts dabei
alter die sonne ist vielleicht total
wir gehen jetzt erstmal so jetzt bitte
ein ganz entspanntes frühstück leute ich
glaube irgendwie sah zehn minuten rum
und sucht ist in dem star
[Musik]
cookies leute leute wieder zurück im
auto vorbei war eine mutter mit zwei
kindern ich hoffe ich habe das gut
gesehen und auch gut gehört ich dachte
so acht kommen die nimmt sich das
bestimmt ihren kaffee mit dann kriegt
ihr sohn noch so ein schönes baguette 1
dargestellt cookie und ein double
chocolate cookie also ich glaube schon
dass ich das richtig verstanden habe
weil das habe ich mir jetzt halt auch
geholt hat auch nur fünf euro gekostet
hier haben wir die beiden sachen weg
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal schlecht
aber ich habe es irgendwie lust auf was
anderes zu früh hätte mich vielleicht
einfach mal noch nicht anstellen sondern
auch die nächste person worten sollte
ist einfach so warm ich habe mir gerade
auch hier ein parkplatz gesucht und die
sonne bald extrem aufs auto raus ist
bisschen wind hat er auch eigentlich gar
nichts mit dem video zu tun
gestern abend hatte ich extremes pech
also für meine verhältnisse und heute
morgen schon wieder jetzt mal beispiel
ist damals bei 99 von 100 bestellungen
bestellt man da doch irgend einem
getränk oder ob es jetzt dieser kaffee
ist oder wie heißt das andere darauf
kino das wort es mir nicht eingefallen
und dann komme ich da an und die vor mir
bestellt einfach zwei cookies
super natürlich schmecken jetzt in
ordnung ich möchte nicht schlecht aber
zum frühstück fand ich keine gucke ich
essen brötchen mit käse und kaffee dazu
wäre auch nicht schlecht leute wir
fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause weil
ein sich die 24 stunden challenge warum
also ich muss wirklich sagen in den
letzten 24 schon habe ich deutlich zu
wenig gegessen es war jetzt war übels
ungesund so was ich bei diesen 24h
challenge ist halt auch in kauf nehmen
muss leider also die laune heute zu
neuen grenzen leute was geht ab die 24
jahren sind vorbei wie es aufgefallen
ein fazit brauche ich eigentlich nicht
machen weil es wird alles im video schon
gesagt wenn ihr sagen alex macht das
noch mal gibt es in die kommentare